who would be on your mount rushmore
of sneaker collectors in the nba you
can't do one without pj obviously
the martyr rosen his his kobe collection
is
od he got stuff that you know you've
never even heard of
i really can't believe that you join our
facebook group like that's that's super
dope man what got you uh interested in
joining custom sneaker battle
i mean i pretty much got into it just to
you know see what's out there
see what see the the custom sneakers
that you know people are
are making and you know what type of
things that you know people like out
there everybody has their own preference
so
i just want to check it out are you an
art enthusiast yourself
i'm into art yeah as far as me having
that skill
i'll say no i've never been great with
the utensil
what about what about you so when did
you start you know customizing sneakers
so for me i was about
13 so i took a pair of horses that i had
that was they were still in good shape
i had a million colored sharpies took
them to school
and it just it turned into something
more than what i expected
so what what would an ideal custom look
like for
you i'm thinking like one of my favorite
shows which was uh avatar last airbender
okay
so i'm like maybe we think about like
the elements or
if you if i want to do a shoe that's
like one based on you know the air
nomads or the fire nation
and i'm thinking that's something that i
think i want to go with for sure
that would be so dope because i mean
number one
i haven't seen many like that in the
first place
okay so in custom sneaker battle it is
customary to show off new heat
what would you show off so i showed you
the the just dons
the curry dunks uh red october easies
this is something that obviously a lot
of people i think want
and just can't get but yeah these are
like these are
three shoes that i that i love like the
red octobers man that's
that's definitely my my favorite shoe
what's your process going into it
you know you i see a white shoe i see
blank and i
and i'm not thinking of anything uh but
what do you what are you thinking of
when you first see a blank slate
it depends when i get ready to put
together a concept
uh it's right straight to the straights
of the pens pencil
sometimes i even paint before i even
paint the shoe
so i'm putting together a storyboard of
all of these
ideas that you had going together in
your head so
how i would design your customs you know
i would definitely like
put that put that aura around you give
you that that glow that energy glow
and hey why why not put like some
geometric shapes in there
to to break it up i'm starting to see it
a little bit obviously you probably you
definitely see it better than i do
again i just like to thank you for
joining our facebook group
custom sneaker battle i'm going to get
some of those concepts uh
roughed up for you get some drafts going
and i will definitely get those customs
to you for sure
again thanks man really appreciate you
uh stepping inside group
yeah no problem man thank you
[Music]